everyone is Jerry I'm on chest cube
another five-minute game okay we have a
game against oh okay
Maury entus we played against each other
let me say hey back we played against
each other in the chest cube World Cup
so I actually I think I know what's
going to be going on here we've played
this opening before many times in both
the tournament and also in the in the
tournament itself so we're going to have
Bishop d3 okay so it's pretty
interesting to be able to play against
somebody who I kind of have a feeling
we'll be going into this particular
opening so Carl Kahn exchange variation
Bishop Bishop g4 Queen c8
we've we've been here many times before
so we'll see we'll see why rattling off
these moves he's going to capture my
bishop to recapture and we're just going
to play from here so I have the the
better Bishop but I still have some work
to do I think I just captured here yeah
that's what I've been doing just
captured before that night before the
the other white knight could make use of
f3 I want to be able to capture here and
have light recapture with either a
bishop or pawn I don't want to have to
tolerate a night on the d5 square so and
now I'm gonna bump my queen up to this
position just to prevent any watch from
Akkad to prevent any checks against my
king but not only that I wanted to
actually get this b5 move in so that's
why that a4 move was played so okay
we've been here before I'm thinking of
either Bishop Bishop d7 I want to do
that Bishop e7 will do and what else so
the the pawn moves that I want to try
and get in are these guys to get some
sort of a minority attack going but
that's a easier said than done so what
do I do cuz if I do this he plays a5 and
then I'm kind of stuck
and what else is there to do if I do b6
then my queen is unprotected in a move
like queen b5 is very good so I'm going
to do this that's not a mouse slip I
want to just keep my king off of that
efile guard my g7 pine-sol I have moves
like this available to me I want to
maybe still reserve the option of having
some target along the H file so although
my king is on Castle you know again
you'll recognize when you do castle
what's actually going on try to get your
king safe and your rook active well my
rook is already active
so maybe castling isn't necessary so
well maybe this is maybe a bit different
let's see how about well actually okay
c4 is coming up trying to take advantage
of the disconnect that I have between my
rooks so this could be a problem
actually you know this could be a
problem let's try this let's try it
Bishop Bishop takes I recapture my Queen
and then I'm hitting h2 maybe the night
oh okay
so let's see here hmm I think this is a
good pawn break here actually I'm going
to back up I want to be able to
recapture on that d5 square with my
queen now the pawn structure can change
very quickly here pawn c5 and then what
am I going to do next that's going to be
a difficult task I think so I might be
going in the wrong direction here so I'm
gonna have to rethink things that Bishop
d6 move was not so hot so I think c5
could really make my position look ugly
pawn takes then I could just recapture
with my knight and my knight is
conveniently watching over that c7
square so that I row can't make use of
it so I think I take I better take I
think or not let me back my queen up boy
this is really iffy here
because actually I can't even rely upon
this night what a sad thing
all right I'm gonna play here and well
he's gonna double I am I'm in a tough
spot
okay pawn takes pawn and what do I do
mm tough spot here well
jeez I don't know I really don't know
what to even do or say I'm seeing a rook
eventually coming down to c8 I'm not
liking that okay I'm gonna run this
direction my king because I want to be
able to connect my rooks so maybe I
should have Castle huh because I think
this c5 mc4 move is quite good for white
you know threatening to just open up the
position and take advantage of that
again that disconnection between my
rooks now this is the rook the white
rook on c3 is very versatile I mean it
could swing over to the to the H file at
any moment in fact actually the Queen
could make use of that square so my king
I can't even rely upon this h7 square
for my King what am i doing this is
messy so I've had actually better
successes in my other games against him
I think I've been able to equalize but
there's certainly improvements that have
been made so Wow what to do here what a
terrible position to have to play
through
in fact my bischoff oh this isn't good
either why did I do that my nights gonna
be captured yeah this is trouble big
trouble what's this guy really doing now
I guess maybe I could get him into play
like that I did this move so that an
eventual white rook won't land on c8
with check I don't know how great that's
going to be actually okay I want to
trade Queens can I make that happen I
really want to just trade Queens and
then play my king because I'm always
fearing like a Queens or something
coming over that h3 square I want to be
able to come to h7 safely we have it we
have a time on both sides under two
minutes now okay I have 30 seconds to
make up
I think I'm happy if the the Queen's are
off okay boy okay yeah I'm gonna go with
this and then okay play b6 stop that
night and also prevent the pawn from
just being captured I think Bishop takes
Knight is important
I want to be able to play my night here
to prevent the the doubling of the rooks
and okay I have to capture first and
then okay so much for preventing the
rooks from getting to the seventh rank
okay I got to come up with something and
that something isn't going to be good
I'm losing everything now rook takes the
pawn on f is a good move first
take that pawn on F and I'm gonna have
to try and save my a seven punt okay
I'm gonna do this and I'm able to
actually weasel out of this I think I
think I'm actually going to be able to
make slow progress yeah that Bishop has
to go to G now it doesn't have to go to
g3 it goes to c7 I'm gonna go here and
I'm actually getting ready to get that
beep on I'm actually sneaking out of
this miraculously I have compensation so
back rank mates hitting the beep on
lights down to a minute I certainly need
to improve upon my play in this game
back to the drawing board for sure so
I'm getting ready to just take that pawn
hit the knight and give back rank me the
rook in the meantime is actually tied
down
well actually oh there's gonna there's
some serious pins going on isn't there
okay let's go with hmmm what do I do
here oh let's go let's go here this is
very very very tight let's see
Knight takes pawn am I gonna have to
fear many things
no no I'm threatening the bishop right
now threatening that Bishop okay and now
I'm threatening that F to pawn Wow okay
so this is what do we do here let's take
this is gonna be a draw isn't it
no I'm the one who's actually fighting
oh that's actually a blunder isn't it
now that the brook has to play to d7 now
we're gonna get into this time scramble
let's see if he's gonna offer me a draw
probably except if he just offers me a
draw because of the time issue is that
really worth the pawn so if you offer me
a job and accept it I promise I guess
he's going for a win up there's the jaw
for I'm gonna accept it
he's a good guy good sportsman as well
so there's certainly a lot of let me
just go here for a second let me just
back up
yeah there's I don't know if he's
prepping for me or what if he maybe just
looked at this radiation because I think
it's certainly an improvement here this
position right here namely a4 is
important otherwise I could get maybe
that b5 advance in and then b4 type of
moves so a4 again is taking into account
the plan that black wants to undertake a
sort of minority attack so after a 4 I'm
kind of in a tough spot and I'm gonna
have to rethink these a King f8 moves
which I again I felt that I was able to
get some good games out of it but c4 c4
and then just the threat of those rooks
invading on the seventh rank and I could
have really been beat badly in fact I
think c5 again was another serious move
to consider c5 with just the intention
of moving the Queen away out of the way
the beep on and then playing b4 b5 and I
mean I'm in a difficult spot there I
really don't know how to actually make
progress so I'm after rethink things
certainly I think actually King f8 is a
something to not do anymore but um what
else is three to even point out here how
can white have maybe even done better
fortunately this b6 move is a good one
because of it just boxes up a knight it
prevents the red from capturing but I
think maybe at this point just capturing
my knight
as soon as I get my knight on d5 it's a
really really strong piece or maybe the
decision to capture on f7 instead of
capture on that f7 square instead of a
seven so so capture this F pawn and then
I can't kick that Bishop away from its
strong post but I'm actually able to
actually get very active very soon and
it was actually white who ended up
having to maybe be a bit careful because
of the main threats and just my night
right here on d5 was actually turning
out to be quite good but certainly a
time for me to go back to the drawing
board out of this opening and so that's
all for this video I hope you got
something out of it take care bye